you're in for a dreadful disappointment  when the committee put the show together  they asked who could ever follow David  Niven and they all agreed nobody so my  name is Tony Randall at this moment I am  to do a seven-minute monologue which is  intensely comical however they've cut it  it's rather too bad because you'd really  have loved it it is now my pleasure to  introduce the two of the silver screens  most decorous delights miss gene Simmons  and mr. Lewis Rajan  we are privileged to present the award  for the best achievement in film editing  gene will you begin the nominees are  William Ziegler for Auntie Mame William  a lion and al Clark for cowboy Frederick  Newton for the Defiant ones Adrian Kazan  for Gigi's William Hornbeck or I want to  live the winner please  Adrian Faison for Gigi  thank you very much everybody